et avec nous pour ce club Malika Sorel
bonjour merci beaucoup d'être là
essayiste donc du collège du Haut
conseil à l'intégration auteur de ce
livre qu'on va voir les damons de la
farce séchés Albin Michel merci d'être
avec nous Didier leski bonjour merci
d'être là directeur général de l'Office
français de l'immigration et de
l'intégration et on va parler justement
et Steve vient de nous a rejoint
rebonjour monsieur
grand débat sur l'immigration le
gouvernement a présenté un projet de loi
qui aurait dû être examiné au Sénat il y
a quelques jours mais finalement
Emmanuel Macron souhaite que la copie
soit revue le texte comportait à la fois
des mesures pour durcir les migrations
et d'autres pour faciliter l'intégration
une mesure contestée par la droite la
création de titre de séjour pour les
travailleurs dans les métiers en tension
on va parler tout ça ce en même temps
est-il tenable ce sera le débat on va
commencer d'abord par ce sondage sondage
BVA qui a été publié hier pour la
Fondation Jean Jaurès à la question y
a-t-il trop d'immigrés aujourd'hui en
France 69 % des personnes interrogées
disent oui qu'est-ce que vous pensez de
ce chiffre Malika Sorel qui est assez
conforme à la réalité cela fait de
nombreuses années je dirais même des
décennies que nous avons un certain
nombre de sondages qui mettent en
évidence le une forme de de colère
maintenant parce qu'au début c'était
une interrogation des Français constater
de plus en plus qui avaient de plus en
plus d'immigrations mais ce qu'il faut
lire en réalité à travers ce chiffre ce
n'est pas qu'il y a de plus en plus
d'immigration c'est qu'il constate que
cette immigration s'intègre
culturellement de moins en moins bien et
c'est ça la préoccupation des Français
c'est observé sur le terrain et
d'ailleurs ce n'est pas une nouveauté
puisque Georges Marchais dès 1981 a été
le premier à véritablement parler de
manière sérieuse de ce sujet en disant
que des problèmes se posaient sur le
terrain des problèmes de cohabitation de
vivre ensemble et que nous pouvions plus
ce sont ces termes continuer ainsi il
abordait également la question
économique c'est dans une lettre que
j'avais exhumée il y a quelques années
dans la nuit de mes livres c'était une
lettre il adressée au recteur de la
Mosquée de Paris Hamza
et il disait nous devons arrêter
l'immigration légale et illégale et la
préoccupation de Georges Marchais était
également le fait et ça reste vrai que
cette immigration en réalité elle est
nuire au travailleur français et qu'elle
ne profitait pas trop na et c'est une
réalité qui a été également attestée par
un grand chercheur américain borjas de
la Harvard School qui produit des
chiffres et qui montre que y compris aux
États-Unis l'immigration sur le plan
économique ne profite qu'au patrona et
aux immigrés eux-mêmes donc ce chiffre
est tout à fait cohérent les Français
ont assez et la question la plus
importante c'est que fait le politique
face que ce soit dans ce domaine ou dans
d'autres dont vous avez parlé
précédemment les retraites etc pourquoi
le politique n'entend-il pas la voix du
peuple et on va parler évidemment tous
ces sujets mais sur ce chiffre 69% c'est
un chiffre en augmentation il était de
63% en 2018 Didier leski c'est un
constat ou c'est une perception de la
part des Français
comment ça c'était le fait est-ce que le
fait que il y a trop d'immigrés
aujourd'hui en France c'est une
perception qui est ressentie par les
Français c'est un problème d'intégration
un problème de vivre ensemble comme le
dit malikachorel bien sûr c'est un
problème social c'est très net du reste
sur le plan des chiffres bien évidemment
il n'y a jamais eu autant d'immigrés en
France on le sait parce qu'il y a une
progression régulière entre 10 et 12% de
la population est immigré c'est à dire
née étrangère à l'étranger il faut
rappeler que 2 millions et demi de
personnes à qui la nationalité française
après quand on regarde le détail de ce
sondage justement on voit bien que le
refus ou la crainte est liée à des
choses très précises on parle
d'insécurité et d'islamistes c'est pour
ça qu'il faut prendre l'immigration au
pluriel il y a des immigrations qui ont
des parcours d'insertion qui sont pas
les mêmes en fonction d'abord de ce que
sont les personnes de leur niveau de
diplôme leur capacité à s'insérer sur le
marché du travail ou pas et puis il y a
le l'écart culturel qui joue de plus en
plus entre certains pays d'immigration
et nous et qui accentuent les
difficultés et quand on voit dans le
détail ce 68% quand on le regarde quels
sont les catégories sociales qui sont le
plus intèdes et bien bien évidemment
c'est celle qui peuvent avoir des
difficultés par exemple pour se loger
puisqu'il y a une concurrence de fait
sur le logement
lié aussi aux dynamiques foncières
d'une inquiétude pour vous de la part
des Français alors les Français en
général ça n'existe pas mais il est
révélateur en tout cas quand on regarde
dans le détail de catégories sociales
qui sont elles prises dans des
difficultés de plus en plus importantes
bien évidemment on prend une ville comme
Paris ou si on fait un sondage on va
dire que la population est globalement
accueillante mais la dynamique de Paris
c'est qu'il y a de moins en moins de
d'ouvriers depuis très longtemps
de les familles sont plutôt expulsées du
fait de prix du foncier et donc quand on
se dit accueillant et bien le constat
c'est que
alors que le nombre d'immigrés ne cessé
d'augmenter dans la population générale
la particularité de Paris c'était 30%
d'immigrés dans les années 80
aujourd'hui ce n'est plus que 20% et
donc on voit bien que on a des coeurs de
ville qui vont à rebours de la situation
de l'augmentation avec
encore en l'air une concentration de
l'immigration dans certaines zones c'est
le problème de la scène samedi par
exemple un mot pour qu'on se situe le la
part du nombre d'immigrés en France par
rapport aux autres pays d'Europe c'est
comparable c'est absolument comparable
la
particularité de la France c'est de la
longue durée et ce qui fait que vous
avez cette étude qui est paru la semaine
dernière dont vous avez dû parler tire
trajectoire et Régine sur trois
générations et bien un tiers de la
population a un lien avec l'immigration
voilà mais on est comparable aux autres
pays c'est c'est ce deuxième chiffre qui
lui n'est pas comparable il faut se
souvenir que dans les années 20 et 30 la
France recevait plus d'étrangers en
proportion de sa population que les
États-Unis c'est ça le et puis le
deuxième problème enfin ou ce qui crée
aujourd'hui des problèmes c'est les
cartes culturelles dont on vient de de
parler c'est le basculement des origines
de l'immigration depuis la fin du 19e
siècle disons jusqu'au au au début des
années 80 la majorité de l'immigration
est une immigration de proximité c'est
l'époque des Portugais des Espagnols des
des Italiens ou un peu plus loin mais
disons européennes les japonais dans
dans le Nord les Juifs d'Europe de l'Est
etc et puis on a un basculement qui se
fait en proportion à partir de des
années 80 90 où on a une présence de
majoritaire maintenant aujourd'hui de
personnes qui viennent du sud du monde
et la caractéristique d'un certain
nombre de pays et bien c'est qu'elle se
sont éloignés culturellement et
sociétalement de ce que nous sommes et
on a une difficulté parce que si on
n'emmène pas la ça patrie à la semaine
de ses chaussures comme disait Danton on
emmène sa culture c'est se basculement
qui fait que les cartes culturelles et
le fossé culturels se creusent et que
l'intégration et de plus en plus
difficile manifestations pas seulement
alors moi je parle d'intégration
culturelle parc d'intégration pour
revenir sur les propos de Didier leski
on ne pouvons pas comparer la France aux
États-Unis vous comprenez bien que si
nous voulons faire une comparaison c'est
comparer les États-Unis avec l'Europe
parce que en termes de proportion ce
n'est absolument pas comparable et puis
il y a quelque chose qui est extrêmement
important de signaler c'est
effectivement nous ne faisons pas face à
la même immigration en termes de
proportion en France nous avons surtout
des populations qui viennent du monde
des anciennes colonies francophones donc
nous voyons bien que la langue n'est
absolument pas la question alors que
c'est présenté par le gouvernement comme
étant l'alpha et l'oméga et donc c'est
très important d'en parler pour vraiment
lever le lièvre parce que c'est un peu
du n'importe quoi excusez-moi
l'expression
il y a une énorme difficulté dans le
fait que l'intégration culturelle ne se
fait plus
qu'on a eu tendance à la confondre avec
l'insertion économique et ceci alors
même que la France plonge la France
plonge dans les classements nous étions
avant les années 2000 quatrième
puissance mondiale année 2000 cinquième
aujourd'hui 7e et les prévisions des
analyses financiers disent qu'en 2035
c'est-à-dire demain la France sera 10e
puissance mondiale donc c'est tout à
fait incompréhensible que
ui garde à la connaissance de tout ce
qui se produit sur le terrain le défaut
d'intégration culturelle dont on peut
dire un mot comment est-ce qu'il est
perçu sur le terrain y compris à l'école
et en même temps le fait que la France
plonge nous avons une dette qui est
abyssale l'État est François Fillon
l'avait dit en faillite sur ce plan-là
mais l'État est désormais également en
faillite sur la dimension intégration
culturelle qui se mesure au travers d'un
certain nombre de phénomènes nous le
voyons à l'école avec la contestation
assez dure des principes de la
République qui aboutissent à ce que 50%
des enseignants s'autocensure ce qui est
extrêmement préoccupant pour se devenir
économique de la France si les
enseignants ne sont pas en capacité de
transmettre dans de bonnes conditions le
programme scolaire pensez bien que nous
allons continuer à nous effondrer dans
le classement international pizza et sur
les mathématiques par exemple c'est
quand même très important les
mathématiques pour les soeurs
économiques la haute technologie etc
dans le rapport dans le teams l'étude
qui évalue les mathématiques la France
est tout simplement bonne dernière de
l'Union européenne je ne comprends pas
et je pense que beaucoup de Français
sont comme moi ne comprennent pas qu'en
dépit du fait que tous les voyants
soient au rouge le défaut d'intégration
culturel mesurée au travers et la
régression se mesure parce que un
exemple son dagifope 74% des enfants de
moins de 25 ans issus de l'immigration
place la religion au dessus des
principes de la République ils étaient
seulement 25% pour les plus de 35 ans
donc on voit bien qu'il y a une
régression il y a une régression qui se
mesure et les personnes y compris dans
l'enceinte de Paris ces meufs de plus en
plus de voir
une explosion du voile portée par les
femmes et le voile c'est un outil de
ségrégation et pour reprendre le propos
du président Emmanuel Macron il avait
dit le voile nous insécurise le mot est
fort nous insécurise car il ne fait pas
partie de notre civilité c'est à dire de
notre manière des éthique de ne se
comporter entre hommes et femmes comment
est-ce qu'avec tous ces voyants on en
vient à vouloir voter une loi sur
l'immigration pour encore ouvrir les
vannes faire un appel d'air parce que
c'est une réalité Yannick Blanc le
directeur de la police à Paris avait
bien expliqué à chaque fois qu'on
régularise ça fait un appel d'air pour
l'immigration on va parler de cette loi
dans deux secondes mais pour faire
réagir Didier les 6 sur Clo Ie Malika
sur elle il y a une faillite de
l'intégration culturelle aujourd'hui
de l'intégration culturelle c'est que la
situation
qu'est-ce qu'il faisait qu'on intégrait
les personnes on les intégrait beaucoup
par le travail et par l'existence
d'organisation qui encadrait les gens
c'était les organisations syndicales ce
qu'on appelait le mouvement ouvrier le
communisme municipal par exemple à jouer
beaucoup de choses et peut aussi le
christianisme social des ordinations
comme la Jeunesse ouvrière chrétienne
enfin tout ça participait d'une prise en
charge et et
c'était adossé à une structure
économique qui s'est elle effondrée au
moment où l'immigration en particulier
familiale a augmenté il faut se souvenir
que jusqu'à la fin des années 70 il y a
un lien très précis entre développement
économique et immigration et puis à
partir des années 80 on a une
désindustrialisation et qui va
s'accélérer dans les années 2000 et donc
on a des personnes qui ne sont plus en
situation de sociabilité et donc on a un
repli sur soi qui se fait maintenant il
faut pas oublier quand même que notre
problème est un problème de marge de
plus en plus important mais que il reste
toujours une intégration qui se fait de
manière symbolique bien sûr on a par
exemple des ministres qui étaient issus
de l'immigration même un premier
ministre etc et donc on a une
intégration qui se fait notre problème
est un problème de marche et il est
particulièrement important quand les
personnes viennent de pays qui se sont
culturellement sociétalement
éloignez-nous alors que ce il s'était
éloignement était moins fort je veux
dire que quand j'étais jeune par exemple
on discutait de l'Algérie indépendante
et on se demandait savoir si
l'autogestion en Algérie ça pouvait
avoir un avenir en Europe bon
aujourd'hui on voit bien que dans ces
pays la question est celle de
l'islamisme et que là on a une
difficulté qui est de plus en plus forte
et c'est le problème du voile partout
les voiles s'est développé et bien on a
une régression démocratique et qui se
joue en particulier pour les femmes et
malheureusement cette régression et cet
impact politique qui nous vient de
l'extérieur ils touchent les populations
jusqu'ici alors nous n'avons jamais
autant donné d'argent
la politique de la ville engloutit bonne
à la main 17 à 10 milliards par an ce
sont des sommes colossales qui sont
déversées sur la question qu'on appelle
pudiquement des banlieues des quartiers
sensibles on en est arrivé à parler de
territoire perdus de la République
c'est-à-dire que l'État a laissé perdre
des pains entiers de la du territoire
français ce n'est pas anodin de
prononcer ces termes territoire perdu de
la République et nous n'avons jamais
autant donné d'argent donc la question
n'est pas une question économique
il est c'est un fait que lorsqu'on dit
que 74% des jeunes de l'immigration qui
ont suivi l'enseignement moral civique à
l'école se disent place pour eux place
la religion au dessus des lois de la
République on ne peut pas dire que nous
sommes dans un phénomène à la marche
c'est un phénomène qui est extrêmement
grave préoccupant je pense qu'il faut il
faut être humble il faut reconnaître que
la France l'État français excusez-moi en
France l'État français a échoué à
intégrer pour un certain nombre de
raisons Didier lesqui a parlé
effectivement du retour des pays
d'origine
à la religion compressible organisateur
de la cité c'est évident que ça a joué
mais nous avons aujourd'hui des
générations de personnes qui sont même
sur diplômés qui sont au travail et
regarder même dans les chiffres par
exemple qui avait été donnés je prends
cet exemple mais ça permet de mesurer
l'intégration dans les chiffres qui
avaient été donnés par les organisations
il y a un organisme français qui
s'occupe de détecter tout ce qui est
phénomène de radicalisation et à
l'époque des départs en Syrie ils
avaient mis en évidence que les deux
tiers étaient
issus de de classe moyenne et un tiers
de classe supérieure donc continuer à
dire que c'est une question sociale pour
moi c'est véritablement continuer à
passer à côté du problème et tant qu'on
ne regardera pas la réalité en face et
tant qu'on ne prendra pas la mesure du
problème et la colère le français et qui
commence à monter qui va diviser le
peuple qui la divise déjà sur ces sujets
et c'est préoccupant pour la cohésion
nationale nous ne pourrons pas poser les
véritables réformes qu'il faut mener
justement à parler de la loi immigration
qui a été présenté en Conseil des
ministres qui a commencé à être
travaillé au Sénat cette loi elle
comportait deux parties Steve dont une
qui visait à durcir notre politique
d'accueil quel objectif expulsé plus
d'étrangers délinquants c'est le but
inquiété fixé par Gérald Darmanin qui
est en charge de ce volet du projet de
loi on va voir quelques chiffres selon
les données officielles pour l'année
2022 les demandes d'asile ont augmenté
de 31% sur la même période les
expulsions d'étrangers ont progressé de
15% au total un peu plus de 15000
éloignements ont été réalisés l'année
dernière dans le détail selon le
ministère de l'Intérieur toujours
3615 étrangers délinquants ont été
expulsés le gouvernement veut aller plus
loin Gérald de Darmanin souhaite en
expulser 4000 de plus par an écoutez-le
et je le sais les étrangers délinquants
on a besoin d'une loi j'en ai besoin
pour en expulser 4000 par an de plus on
en fait déjà 3000 par an pour simplifier
notre droit pour mieux intégrer les
personnes étrangères il y a des
discussions vous le savez bien que le
Sénat et la semaine nationale mais je
pense que les choses et sont tout à fait
possible pour le coup de trouver une
majorité avec LR sur ce point et si
comment Gérald Darmanin veut faire pour
expulser davantage alors avant son
report pour cause de mobilisation contre
la réforme des retraites le texte
prévoyait notamment une réforme
structurelle de notre système d'asile et
du contentieux des étrangers on va voir
quelques mesures qui étaient prévues par
le texte il était notamment question
d'une réduction des protections contre
les au cutf les individus ne pourront
plus revendiquer des attaches en France
comme le fait d'être marié à un français
pour obtenir la remise en cause de
l'obligation de quitter le territoire
autre mesure la simplification des
procédures contentieuses idées c'est de
réduire le nombre de recours
susceptibles d'être engagés par les
étrangers devant le juge on est en
compte actuellement 12 Gérald Darmanin
vais réduire à 3 et puis il était aussi
question d'un assouplissement des
procédures d'expulsion contre les
lettres étrangers condamnés ils peuvent
aujourd'hui être expulsés en cas de
terrorisme ou de crimes grave il
pourrait désormais l'être également en
cas de condamnation pour un crime ou un
délit puni de 10 ans ou plus de prison
on élargit donc le spectre des personnes
expulsables est-ce que le gouvernement
peut compter sur le Sénat c'est ce qui
est super le gouvernement mais en
commission les sénateurs ont d'ores et
déjà dit qu'il fallait encore muscler le
projet de loi parmi les mesures
demandées par les LR on trouve notamment
l'instauration d'une politique de quota
pour toutes les catégories d'immigration
un durcissement des critères du
regroupement familial ou encore une
réforme de LED médical d'État qui
deviendrait une aide médicale d'urgence
et d'urgence seulement faut-il durcir
notre politique migratoire comme
souhaitait le faire le gouvernement et
encore plus la droite sénatoriale
il faut en tout cas revoir les
procédures et du reste le gouvernement
s'inspirait d'un rapport de la
commission des Lois du Sénat et c'était
ça qui était introduit dans le texte
ainsi que d'un rapport du Conseil d'État
il faut se souvenir que aujourd'hui la
moitié du contentieux administratif en
français est lié au droit des étrangers
et que ce droit aujourd'hui il n'y a que
des hyperspécialistes qui arrivent à en
comprendre l'ensemble des subtilités
mais bien évidemment il faut accélérer
les retours de ceux qui ne doivent pas
rester sur le territoire parce que c'est
le seul moyen d'avoir je dirais même une
politique de visa c'est parce que on a
une politique de retour qui doit être
possible qu'il faut en contrepartie
avoir des visas et si on n'a pas cette
politique de retour et bien maintenez il
faut s'interroger sur l'existence
possible d'une migration circulaire mais
le problème des reconduites il est pas
simplement lié au droit on le sait bien
et on en a en ce moment des exemples et
des débats il est lié aussi au fait que
les pays d'origine pour certains d'entre
eux
refuse de reprendre une partie de leur
de leur ressortissants alors même qu'ils
n'ont plus à rester ici et c'est toute
la difficulté et c'est le président de
la République à un moment donné à mis
sur la table la question de la
délivrance des visas mais c'est ça le
Hard un des Francs
des obligations de quitter le territoire
français c'est exactement cela après il
y a d'autres mesures en particulier des
mesures d'intégration qui feront que la
France sera à peu près enfin rejoindra
un certain nombre de pays qui sont
beaucoup plus attachés à leur langue que
nous il faut souvenirs historiquement on
n'est pas français parce qu'on parle
français on est allemand parce qu'on
parle allemand il faut se souvenir que
en Allemagne même pour l'immigration
familiale on peut avoir le visa que si
on a un niveau A1 ce qui est proposé par
le gouvernement c'est le titre
pluriannuel lié à un niveau de langue
aujourd'hui le niveau de langue il est
il existe pour avoir la carte de
résident la carte de 10 ans et il existe
pour avoir la nationalité française et
c'est important parce que même dans la
demande d'asile on a de plus en plus de
personnes qui sont très loin de de la
Francophonie et on peut penser par
exemple aux Afghans on est un des pays
de la demande d'asile afghane ou
d'autres pays mais même dans les pays
historiquesment liés à la Francophonie
on a une perte de la Francophonie on a
eu la fabiatisation en arabe dans les
pays du Maghreb qui a beaucoup touché
aujourd'hui des personnes qui viennent
en France et qui n'ont pas le niveau de
français
mais juste puisque
Didier leski en parle on va voir un
reportage Audrey vutaz et Adrien pain
justement nous emmène suivre certains de
ces citoyens dont des Afghans ont pris
en charge par l'Office français de
l'immigration et de l'intégration lors
de leur formation linguistique et c'est
un défi parce que beaucoup n'étaient
même pas scolarisés dans leur pays
d'origine on regarde
laetitia est arrivé en France car sa vie
était menacée en Côte d'Ivoire depuis 6
mois elle suit des cours de français
l'enseignante à la super cool elle a
expliqué
même si la Côte d'Ivoire est francophone
Laeticia a des lacunes en lecture et en
écriture je vais apprendre à mon fils de
pouvoir lire écrire et sa fille aussi
dans la société je le fais pour moi et
pour mes enfants et de pouvoir aussi
s'assumer intellectuellement aussi dans
le milieu social qui est dans le travail
c'est même mon but ce n'est pas de
m'arrêter là avec elle ama les goulzama
deux afghans qui ont un rêve pouvoir
travailler un jour en France
la maison
[Musique]
en pleine exercice de conjugaison mais
comme ici
il y a un H et que le H ne prononce pas
mais qu'il y a une voyelle on fait la
liaison nous habitons
très bien dans la salle certains sont
réfugiés d'autres en procédure de
regroupement familial
comme tout citoyen non européen admis au
séjour en France et prise en charge par
l'Office français de l'immigration et de
l'intégration ils doivent suivre une
formation linguistique un château
et oui après une évaluation on leur a
prescrit 400 heures de français
l'objectif atteindre ce qu'on appelle le
niveau A1 c'est ce qu'on appelle le
niveau de survie pour survivre dans un
environnement qui parle cette langue
pour apprendre à se présenter à prendre
poser des questions simples etc on
aborde le présent le présent simple
et c'est déjà beaucoup parce que le
français c'est pas facile à apprendre
quand même le français n'est pas facile
à apprendre et beaucoup dans la salle
n'ont pas eu la chance d'aller à l'école
dans leur pays pour nous qui n'avons
jamais été scolarisés c'est un peu
difficile de pouvoir retenir certains
mots par exemple on dit bureau manger du
vélo donc c'est à fois compliqué mais
avec la répétition on arrive à des
phrases pour l'instant il n'y a qu'une
évaluation à mi-parcours et à la fin des
400 heures mais des voix s'élèvent pour
la création d'un examen formel ce qui ne
serait pas sans conséquence est-ce que
le niveau qui va être arrêté est-ce que
ça ne va pas sans sonner une partie de
de du public qui est en apprentissage et
en progressant régulièrement quand on
parle d'examen c'est un stress
supplémentaire pour les bénéficiaires
c'est c'est vraiment
ça peut être démoralisant pour la
personne Gérald Darmanin le ministre de
l'Intérieur voudrait tout de même que
cet examen conditionne l'obtention ou
non d'un titre de séjour
et précision de Didier lesquelles et
Malika Sorel on voit ce reportage est-ce
que l'intégration passe par la maîtrise
de la langue non pas nécessairement pas
au début c'est à dire que pour moi le la
maîtrise de la langue ne doit pas être
une condition si on prend cette
condition je donne un exemple précis
mais il y en a beaucoup qui pourraient
en parler également c'est que le
l'époque de mes parents
les gens ne parlaient très mal de
français beaucoup étaient analphabètes
ça ne les a aucunement empêché de faire
en sorte que leurs enfants respectent la
France la loi de la République et vous
m'avez aujourd'hui devant vous et on
nous n'avons jamais eu aucun problème
vis-à-vis de l'État français ni de son
histoire ni de sa culture ce n'est plus
du tout le cas comment peut-on
aujourd'hui sérieusement vraiment là je
fais appel Géraldine président de la
République comme on peut on aujourd'hui
alors que nous avons des enfants de la
troisième génération qui parfaite
maîtrise parfaitement la langue de
Molière qui en vienne à dire à leurs
enseignants je vais te faire une Samuel
Paty etc et vendre aux Français essayer
de leur vendre que c'est parce qu'on va
dire si vous ne parlez pas français vous
ne pourrez pas vous intégrer
culturellement non le problème est
ailleurs nous avons eu du fait de
l'importance des flux migratoires une
reconstitution des peuples d'origine sur
le sol français aujourd'hui quelqu'un
qui arrive contrairement à l'époque de
mes parents éprouvera la plus grande
difficulté à s'intégrer culturellement
lorsqu'il vient des mêmes airs
culturelles parce que Monsieur le qui en
a parlé j'en ai beaucoup parlé dans mes
livres il y a eu dans ces pays d'origine
un retour vers la religion et dès 1987
dans un rapport de l'Union européenne il
était précisé que pour la plupart des
migrants culture et religions se
confondaient et qu'il y avait parfois et
même souvent c'est exactement ce qui est
écrit dans ce rapport je cite dans mon
livre des valeurs qui sont contraires
aux sociétés d'accueil européenne donc
occidentale et c'est ça qui fait que
aujourd'hui ce qui aurait pu s'intégrer
culturellement ne le pourront pas
nécessairement parce que leur peuple
d'origine s'étend les communautés on
parle de communauté aujourd'hui c'est un
reconstituer sur la terre d'accueil
elles vont empêcher exercer une pression
sur les jeunes et regarder ce que dit le
dernier rapport de l'INSEE en disant
nous avons doublement du nombre de
femmes voilées j'avais posé la question
un jour au conseil de Dominique de
Villepin que pour lequel j'ai travaillé
2000 de Villepin
et nous avions parlé la question des
femmes voilées et spontanément il
m'avait dit ah non une femme voilée
n'est pas une française alors pourquoi
en étant arrivé à ne pas poser la
question de fond qui n'est pas présente
dans ce rapport parce que en réalité
pour moi ce rapport je l'écris dans
Figaro c'est un rapport qui vise à
régulariser les illégaux c'est à dire
l'état français se permet de dire vous
avez violé la loi française nous allons
vous donner une récompense Yannick Blanc
parler des effets pervers pourquoi
est-ce que le sujet de plus important
n'est pas mis sur la table et qui pose
aujourd'hui un question français c'est
la question du droit à la nationalité
comment donne-t-on la nationalité
française qui est un titre de propriété
de la terre souvenez-vous territoire
perdu de la République partition de
François Hollande a des personnes qui ne
sont pas culturellement françaises c'est
à dire qu'ils ne vivent pas comme les
Français n'adopte pas la liberté
individuelle donc pas de pression sur
l'individu le fait qu'il peut choisir sa
vie l'égalité homme-femme la laïcité qui
est demande de notre de notre façon de
vivre ensemble et la fraternité et tant
qu'on posera pas cette question du code
de la nationalité nous n'y arriverons
pas et pour moi ce projet de loi et
c'est de la poudre de perlimpinpin qui
qui véritablement là pour faire en sorte
que nous ne légalisions les clandestins
et moi j'appelle les sénateurs à tenir
droit parce que nous ne pouvons pas en
tant que état dire vous avez le droit de
violer la loi et même de violer la
constitution parce que la République
française est laïque etc et obtenir la
nationalité française et je vous laisse
conclure d'ici il y a beaucoup de choses
dans ce cas tu m'as dit qu'elle soit je
sais pas sur quoi vous vous souhaitez
réagir du coup
je fonctionnaire je fais pas de
politique donc c'est un peu la politique
migration ces politiques
si vous voulez on a bien évidemment un
problème d'intégration pour une partie
de l'immigration il faut pas se dire
prendre cette partie qui pose problème
74% des jeunes c'est de la France il
faut pas prendre cette partie qui pose
problème pour l'ensemble de
l'immigration d'autant que ces arrivées
sont multiples par exemple on a de plus
en plus une immigration chinoise qui
pose des problèmes mais qui ne sont pas
les mêmes que celles qui vient de pays
où comme le dit
ce qui vient d'être dit on de la
question de la religion et de plus en
plus prégnant et c'est accéléré au fil
des décennies la deuxième chose c'est
que à travers la langue on apprend une
culture mais que on reste suffisant
monsieur l'esprit vous savez nous avons
de l'école on apprend une culture ça
mais que bien évidemment il n'y a aucun
mécanisme qui automatiquement permet aux
personnes d'être complètement acculturé
en particulier pour certains groupes qui
ne sont pas la majorité il faut faire
attention de ne pas confondre certains
courants et certaines situations avec
l'ensemble de l'immigration mais les
problèmes ils existent en France il
existe en Allemagne on l'a vu par
exemple ce week-end je veux dire une
manifestation où on crie mort aux juif à
Berlin on voit bien on voit bien que on
a la des problèmes majeurs qui ne sont
pas spécifiques à la France donc il faut
continuer le travail il faut être
rigoureux du point de vue de
l'application des lois c'est indéniable
c'est ce qui était proposé en partie par
le projet de loi il faut comprendre que
la question est autant juridique que
sociale parce que le logement par
exemple est un frein à l'intégration dès
lors qu'il n'y a pas suffisamment alors
pourquoi continuer avec l'immigration et
nous n'avons pas parler
des états
on aura l'occasion de refaire un débat
parce que là malheureusement tant pis il
y aura encore beaucoup beaucoup de
grands avec nous on va regarder la une
de nos quotidiens régionaux
[Musique]
Steve la grève est levée la raffinerie
Gonfreville
Normandie les salariés de Total énergie
ont mis fin hier alors mouvement contre
la réforme des retraites après cinq
semaines de débrayage et un arrêt de la
raffinerie pendant trois semaines les
salariés ont jeté l'éponge en raison
peut-on lire d'un manque de motivation
la grève n'avait plus de sens explique
un délégué syndical CGT le week-end
dernier il n'y avait plus que 10
grévistes contre 40 débuts du mouvement
en conséquence d'activité va reprendre
dans la raffinerie plongée dans la zone
interdite oui cette belle une de la
Provence aujourd'hui le journal propose
un reportage au coeur des rues
sinistrées de Marseille après
l'effondrement d'un immeuble le dimanche
au 17 rue de Tivoli le journal fait un
point sur l'enquête et s'intéresse au
réseau de gaz et un compteur retrouvé
dans les décombres l'hypothèse qui tient
la corde est toujours celle d'une
explosion au gaz y a-t-il eu
consommation anormale du côté d'une
gazinière réponse dans quelques heures
quelques jours on l'espère des dizaines
d'enquêteurs sont en tout cas sur le
pont focus sur les casseurs bretons oui
c'est à dire dans le Télégramme
aujourd'hui le journal se demande qui
sont
ceux qui cassent lors des manifestations
contre la réforme des retraites le
constat est clair les personnes
interpellées lors des mobilisations non
pas le profil des militants violents qui
sont issus de groupuscules organisés il
s'agit la plupart du temps de citoyens
en colère ils ont le visage de tous les
français écrit le journal salarié
chômeurs SDF lycéen étudiant
l'interpeller type a le profil de
monsieur tout le monde enquête très
intéressante à dire aujourd'hui dans le
Télégramme on termine par la bataille du
lait qui est déclaré effectivement rien
ne va plus l'avenir du Reblochon est
peut-être menacé nous dit Le Dauphiné
Libéré en Haute-Savoie un fromage
historique a été racheté l'été dernier
par Lactalis on assiste depuis à une
levée de boucliers des producteurs et
des coopératives laitières du coin il
s'organise pour éviter de faire géant de
l'agroalimentaire un leader local vive
le reblochon vive les Savoyards regarde
merci beaucoup si tu penses à trouver
presque merci beaucoup Malika Sorel
d'avoir été avec nous on regarde on
revoit votre livre les dindons de la
farce sécher Albin Michel et merci
beaucoup Didier leski et on aura
l'occasion de refaire un débat parce que
il y a évidemment encore beaucoup de
sujets à aborder sur cette question de
l'immigration merci à tous de nous avoir
suivi à 15h la séance de questions
d'actualité au Gouvernement au Sénat et
puis à 18h vous avez rendez-vous
pour cette très bonne journée à demain
[Musique]